so soccer disrespect isn't even back yet
but his inevitable return to twitch has
people asking a lot of questions some
people are wondering if he should even
be allowed back some people are asking
twitch to be more transparent with how
it handles cases like his and some
people are saying that being banned was
actually good friend right so you may
remember two weeks ago when we told you
about doctors respect to ban from twitch
in case you missed that video please
watch it to find out more but the TLDR
is that doc string from a bathroom at e3
which is extremely illegal and got him
banned from twitch since then a few
things have happened first
twitch lifted Doc's ban after just two
weeks now doc hasn't actually streamed
anything yet but when people found out
his channel was back they allegedly
flooded him with followers and new subs
then again before he actually streamed
anything on July 1st guy beamed the man
behind the mustache issued an apology
for what happened at e3 in his apology
beam said what pretty much everybody was
thinking it was an honest mistake he got
caught up in the character and he just
really didn't think about what he was
doing
quote when we were walking around
filming at e3 we clearly weren't
thinking about the laws slash
repercussions of filming in the bathroom
because honestly it wasn't in our mind
frame at the time we were sort of all in
with the doc livestream experience and
capturing the e3 events was a character
we were so into the e3 IRL journey that
we became a little blind in what's okay
and what's not okay
anyway presumably beam is doing all of
this because doc is returning to twitch
on July 8th and he wants to get all his
ducks in a row before that he wants his
return to be huge but I think at the end
of the day it was always gonna be huge
and if your twitch that's kind of a
problem see this has all happened before
literally it's happened to dr.
disrespects before in 2018 beams took a
two-month break after admitting to
having cheated on his wife twitch didn't
ban him or anything he just took two
months off to focus on his family but
his return was crazy he came back to a
record breaking stream with new theme
music composed by deadmau5 in over three
hundred and eighty eight thousand
concurrent viewers the highest twitch
had ever seen on an individual stream
this has actually happened a lot soda
Poppins man from twitch in 2018 led to
freestream numbers for him and it's also
happened to Tifa it doesn't even require
being banned from twitch Tyler ones
return to League of Legends also broke
twitch records and x2 C's banned from
overwatch actually made him more famous
than ever before hell it doesn't even
require doing something dumb like being
toxic or breaking the law shroud was
banned some pub G and his return was
also huge for him on twitch this isn't a
new thing in fact several members of the
twitch community have noted that getting
banned can be huge for a major streamer
last night is like when Shifu got banned
he comes back to burn streams are insane
it always seems to be I mean everyone
knows the return streams that have
happened in the past even with Doc and
other streamers and it's like it's like
your community rallies right back around
you yep and even if the ban is deserved
it's like it's like he's back from
vacation it's like he's we missed you of
my and it's and people my timeline we're
talking about even other pretty
prominent streamers were like is that
something that twitch pass it like
address at some point it's like courage
said in that clip the community rallies
around them and whether the ban was
warranted or not that return stream is
gonna be huge this kind of sucks in
cases where the band is totally
warranted whoa I don't think that Doc's
should have been banned for life but I
do think that two weeks seems like a
relatively light slap on the wrist given
he literally broke the law and did
something gross and unethical even if it
was an honest mistake
but by banning him twitch essentially
covered his inevitable return stream in
gasoline it is going to be huge possibly
even bigger than his last
record-breaking return stream coming
back from a ban to even more success
than you had from before you were banned
is not something twitch wants to happen
if twitch wants these bans to be a
punishment for misbehavior then they
shouldn't inevitably lead to increased
popularity that goal doesn't add up with
that results now if you want to put on
your tinfoil hat there's a possibility
that which kind of does want this look
at the end of the day twitch is a
business and Doc brings in huge numbers
why wouldn't they want him to be even
more popular we can't know for sure
but that is something worth considering
but for now let's operate under the
assumption that twitch uses bands as a
form of punishment and this isn't
working out for them and listen I know
what the counter-argument to this sounds
like going to weeks is that streaming is
a ton of
chill income loss for a major streamer
so much so that it's a severe punishment
even when you factor in that enormous
return stream when chief who got banned
last year he said he lost eleven
thousand subs and that's a lot of money
but it's really hard to put a numerical
value on what this kind of drama and
controversy can do for a streamers
profile the world of twitch moves very
very fast and this just puts off in the
headlines obviously he wasn't in any
danger of slowing down but he's more
relevant than he ever was before people
who have never watched doc before will
likely tune into his return stream and
some of those people will probably
become subs a lot of those people who
unsubscribe for him might even Reese
absque ribe when they see he's back on
stream if everything goes right it's a
win-win he got a ton of publicity a
two-week vacation and the potential for
a huge career boosting comeback it's
hard to see where exactly twitch can
construe this as a serious punishment
for breaking the law so what's the
solution
well courage actually pitched a possible
one on his podcast with nadeshot he said
a couple the 30-day banned let's say
with a 30-day removal of your sub pup
this idea is really interesting because
if twitch is actually using news bans as
punishment this does prevent streamers
from capitalizing on their bans sure
they're gonna have a major return stream
but at least they're not squeezing more
subs out of that return then again if
those new potential subs stick around
there's a chance that we just get a
second huge comeback day when the sub
button returns it solves the immediate
issue of the huge comeback stream but if
you're twitch it doesn't solve the
problem that people are profiting off of
their bans at the end of a talk didn't
do any of this for shitty reasons but he
did get banned and you'll probably get a
huge sub bump off of it so what's to
stop the next guy from doing something
shitty on purpose getting banned and
maybe think the same thing happened to
him thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]